[Música]
el horror de la guerra se representa en
los civiles atrapados en el conflicto y
sobre todo en los niños el número total
de personas que han huido de ucrania
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa ha
superado ya los 3 millones mientras esta
situación sanitaria en el país es
preocupante los combates lo distinguen y
según las autoridades ucranianas son ya
103 niños los que han muerto desde el
inicio de la guerra 11 1.5 millones de
menores ya forman parte de lo que es
este éxodo de ucranianos a un ritmo de
casi un niño por cada segundo desde que
comenzó la guerra el pasado 24 de
febrero esto según unicef
polonia es el país que más personas
acoge con alrededor de 1.8 millones de
refugiados según la acnur y para ello
entonces quiero saludar en este momento
a nuestro segundo invitado del día el es
vicente raymundo director de cooperación
internacional de save the children en
españa gracias vicente por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
hablé más entonces la situación general
de los niños hablemos primero de los que
han huido de esta guerra
bueno gracias a ustedes y buenos días
creo que las peores previsiones se han
hecho realidad y eso es algo atroz no se
han cumplido todavía tres semanas desde
el comienzo de la guerra en ucrania y ya
hemos pasado de tres millones de
personas que se han visto forzadas a
huir de su país cada segundo
un niño se convierte en refugiado
saliendo de ucrania viviendo del
conflicto de los tres millones como
mencionabas muy bien pues mínimo un 40
45 50 por ciento son son menores de edad
son niñas y niños que han visto cómo su
vida drásticamente
cambiaba de un día de un día para otro
tenemos también que hablar de los que se
han tenido que quedar dentro de ucrania
y su situación es comparativamente peor
que nuestros compañeros del cruz roja y
de otras instituciones que merecen todo
el respeto y la credibilidad hablan de
una situación apocalíptica tenemos
amigos millones de personas dentro de
ucrania que no pueden no pueden huir
porque entienden que su vida se pondría
aún más en peligro si se hubieran y la
ayuda humanitara especializada no llega
a ellos entonces de se detendrán lo que
pedimos es que reglas de la guerra que
existen reglas se cumplan que el derecho
internacional humanitario se cumpla y
que pese a que ha habido momentos
concretos y excepcionales en los que la
población ha podido huir y la ayuda
humanitaria a llegar a ellos éstos
siguen siendo excepcionales pedimos de
verdad que chrome sino adelante qué es
lo que están pidiendo pues pedimos que
las reglas se respeten decir que que la
población civil es sagrada y hay que
respetarla que las infraestructuras
civiles son sagradas que no se pueden
atacar intencionadamente
infraestructuras civiles no se pueden
atacar depósitos de agua de combustible
escuelas hospitales orfanatos que la
gente tiene que poder salir y la ayuda
humanitaria poder llegar a ellos y esto
no es negociable cuáles son los derechos
que principalmente se están vulnerando
en medio de esta guerra hablamos de
salud de educación en alimentación y
sobre todo enfocados en los niños niños
también que están parece parece de cosa
menor en todo este contexto pero también
es importante los niños que no están
accediendo a la educación a la
recreación
absolutamente una de las cosas sin
embargo en toda esta tragedia en todo
este drama hay relativamente buenas
noticias la unión europea la comisión
europea ha tenido un comportamiento
rápido y ejemplar poniendo por fin en
marcha una directiva europea que tiene
más de 20 años de antigüedad que permite
poder garantizar un estatus legal
inmediato a aquellas personas que huyen
de un conflicto ahora mismo en cualquier
familia de ucrania que llega a españa o
cualquier país europeo en españa en
concreto tardan en obtener este estatus
legal entre 20 minutos y 2 horas esto no
tiene precedentes la gente que oye otros
conflictos ayer se cumplieron 11 años
del comienzo de la guerra de siria no
nos olvidemos de aquello
tarda meses en obtener este estatus les
permite a la mañana siguiente tener
derecho a una asistencia pública
gratuita de calidad a la mañana
siguiente a los niños ser escolarizados
asumiendo que pueden ser escolarizados y
a sus padres trabajar estas vías de
acceso legales a servicios públicos que
existen esto es esto es una bendición y
esto está esto estaba sucediendo
respecto al derecho a la educación pedir
el derecho a la educación hoy dentro de
ucrania es realista es decir hay
hallazgo en sus momentos que va primero
que es el derecho a la vida y el derecho
a comer ya poder tener medicinas eso es
lo que tocaría dentro de ucrania perfora
ucrania es relevante y es apropiado